vergisst KFC wenn du dieses japanische
Sesam chicken ist dann brauchst du
nichts anderes mehr zunächst marinieren
wir das Chicken dafür schneide ich es in
kleine Stücke ein Eiweiß zwei geriebene
Knoblauchzehen Backpulver weiße Stärke
und Sojasauce einmal schön
durchmassieren unser mariniertes chicken
geben wir jetzt etappenweise in
Kartoffelstärke in der wir das ganze
benutzen um es dann anschließend zu
frittieren wir Frittieren das Chicken in
zwei Etappen die erste ist vorbei das
holen wir es einmal kurz raus geben lass
uns kurz abkühlen das Chicken ist
doppelt frittiert kümmern wir uns um die
Soße dafür mache ich den Herd an
mittlere Hitze und gebe einfach alles
rein ein bisschen Wasser ein bisschen
Weißweinessig Sojasoße braunen Zucker
Honig Ketchup hier habe ich ein bisschen
Soßenbinder mit Wasser rühre und gucke
dass es ein bisschen dick wird wenn das
so ein bisschen karamellisiert können
wir das schicken hinzugeben und gucken
dass es von allen Seiten gleichmäßig
bedeckt wird von unserer Soße wenn das
der Fall ist können wir ein bisschen
Sesam dazu geben so wie ein bisschen
Sesamöl jetzt etwas rein unser Sesam
schicken jetzt noch ein bisschen
Frühlingszwiebel